bonsoir
c'est ya les cheveux extrêmement bien de
couper l'eau mais vraiment un jeu trop
non avec bada je suis fascinée là
vraiment ça va très très bien fou ce
lien vous bien alors booba il rigole
paul tu rigole pas tous eu le dessus ça
va mal 27 ans
2 album certifié disque d'or deux
passages en prison on commence par la
prison comme ça ça sera fait donc
d'abord quatre ans pour avoir agressé
deux chauffeurs de taxi et qu'une arme à
feu moi je suis mais liberté
conditionnelle au bout de 18 mois
pourquoi ce que
tu as à mars alors c'était pas méchant
ils ont été un peu dure un peu dur avec
moi ouais ensuite quatre mois de
préventive pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire l'ats le procureur a réclamé
trois ans mais vous avez été relaxé
parce que j'étais innocent ouais tu
regrettes
je regrette de m'être fait rattraper
surtout me tu dis que les gens qui sont
en prison en fait y en a très peu qui
elle va tu
ton qu'on sait pas faire attraper je ne
connais peu qu'ils vont se rendre de
leur plein gré comme en position je
regrette ce que j'ai fait
ou alors vous êtes booba métisse franco
sénégalais mais dans les hauts-de-seine
vers 10-11 ans quand vos parents
divorcent vous partez avec votre mère à
cagnes-sur-mer et l'été de vos quinze
ans vous avez aux usa et vous dites est
là c'est intéressant par rapport à ce
que dit payant non je ne crois pas du
tout à l'intégration je préfère le
système des communautés à l'américaine
donc vous pensez que l'intégration
républicaine à la française c'est un
modèle obsolète
ouais je pense que c'est hypocrite ouais
on aimait chez soi avec les gens qui
nous ressemblent c'est pas sans être
sectaire mais ouais aux états unis voilà
quoi dit encore eric on se retrouve
ensemble ils sont ensemble à manhattan
par exemple n'y a pas de problème le
soir ils se retrouvent chez eux ils
n'ont pas de tensions ils fondèrent un à
noter avec les gens qui on ne regarde
pas de d'otan bas
chacun chez soi moi je préfère en tout
cas un modèle où on peut avoir des gens
qui sont divers et qui vivent ensemble
plutôt que d'être chacun dans son coin
et je pense quand même que ce modèle est
un modèle qui amène entre ces
communautés à des violences qui sont
extrêmement profonde et avec des
communautés qui sont quand même beaucoup
plus en difficulté que l'autre
ça me semble pas un modèle très
souhaitable je pense qu'on avait réussi
à faire ensemble c'est difficile à faire
alors qu'on dit je moi je préfère l
autre avec ceux qui sont comme moi etc
on le comprend tous parce qu'on a tous
un peu ça mais de là à dire sans les
autres c'est difficile mais j'ai fait
une interview l'année dernière à la
prison fleury mérogis et je leur
expliquais que éventuel 20 je leur
posais la question à savoir la d'être en
prison maintenant ici est ce que ça leur
permettait à eux d'avoir une remise en
question sur eux-mêmes et éventuellement
d'évoluer devoirs et les gammes disait
non parce que en fait on nous replonge
comme ils émettent par secte par secteur
c'est ça mon temps communautés en
présence il est légal et wigan
sa créance de documentaires on nous
replonge dedans si on si effectivement
on était un petit peu là là là là là on
serait en fait on se retrouve tous les
mêmes qui étaient dans les cités à faire
des conneries se retrouvent pareils sont
donc ils peuvent pas évoluer il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas un vrai travail un
suivi pour essayer justement de le leur
ouvrir d'autres horizons pas pour pour
pour vous l'avenir et au communautarisme
en fait vous pensez que l'intégration
républicaine c'est un modèle dépassé je
pense en tout cas ici sa force pas à
prendre ouais ça marche pas parce que
vous dites vous par exemple quand il
fallait me réinscrire au collège
ma mère me disait tout montre pas comme
ça ma mère elle est blanche s'en passe
mieux ouais
par exemple vous dites en france même
avec une belle voiture tu te fais
contrôler deux fois par jour il ya
toujours vous dites ce plafond qu'on
n'arrive pas à percer il ya quel que
soient les moyens dont on dispose
quand on est noir on sera toujours un
sous citoyen c'est ce que vous dites en
fait moi je pense avoir à
penser que c'est sans espoir
je sais pas trop d'espoir ce niveau là
tu vois c'est quand même mais s'ils
disent ah enfin moi ce que j'entends
c'est qu'en même temps il ya une forme
de regret parce que je vois pas pourquoi
il serait pas un citoyen comme les
autres donc ça condamne pas le modèle
républicain sadi là ils marchent mal
passé ses huit sons qu'il marche pas
mais où qui marchent pas à mon avis ça
marche mieux quand même que là où il
n'ya pas mais et il a des ratés terrible
il a des ratés depuis 20 ans
considérable et d'ailleurs on voit les
brisures moi ça me donne plutôt le
sentiment qu'il faudrait que ça marche
mieux me dire ce modèle là c'est vrai on
pense tous à la baule
il ya des gens qui croient plus du tout
âge et bien
c'est inquiétant vous dites je raconte
la dure réalité le mal de vivre si on
mettait mes textes en images ce serait
sûrement interdit aux moins de 16 ans
que des textes extrêmement violent il ya
même dans votre cv comment violence à
votre cd qui bâtiment c'est quand même
pas reproduit sur le livre est tellement
les lieux alors ça pour éviter les
ennuis avec la justice sur l une des
range post ex1 et violent mais bon pour
moi c'est la
normalité alors votre nouvel album qui
est le deuxième album solo vous faites
booba s'appelle panthéon c'est chez
barclays
vous pensez que cette musique ce genre
de texte devrait avoir sa place au
panthéon
forcément c'est plus un symbole oui mr
dire qu'on essaye de faire de grandes
choses quoi ouais vos chansons racontent
les gonzesses les flingues les flics les
bandes des cités la cam est la plus
sympa tout
ces numéros 10 si la plus optimiste
alors on vous compare à jeûner en vous
compare à ses lignes et c'est vrai que
finalement on pourrait dire que je n'ai
céline c'était des rappeurs sans musique
personnellement moi j'ai pas lu je
connais pas ce qu'ils font c'est que
c'est des grands écrivains r1 dans ces
produits n'est pas scellé le rouge il
peint
dans la chanson
alors vous êtes le 25 août à bercy avec
fifty cents ouais en première partie
c'est bien
vous sourirez jamais qu'est ce qui
pourrait vous faire plaisir car deux
membres entre de tes questions à la con
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu